So to summarize this overall architectural design process, phase zero
was specifying properties, and this involved constructing the context diagram.
Indicating the external actors but only one activity the system itself.
We indicated external stimuli or events. That can affect the system.
We have the external actors being the user and the file system.
We indicated how the system communicates its results back to the external actor.
Those are the percepts. And then we specified in English, the behaviors that you
want the system to have, and we used as starting point for that, used cases or
scenarios that we developed when we looked at the exercises at the start of
the term. In Phase 1 we componentized. Which meant decomposing the system into
components, reallocating responsibilities to them, for handling events and for
delivering percepts, and we assigned responsibility for the vary,
guaranteeing the various properties. In Phase 2 we chose an architectural style,
and that in turn specified how the components will interact. We chose a layered
implicit invocation architecture, we have assigned the components to layers,
we determined the dependencies between the layers, we updated our guarantees,
we selected an invariant maintenance strategy, and we've assigned,
in doing so, that assigned responsibility for maintaining those invariants.